in deep space two black holes circled
each other their mass propagating
gravitational waves across the fabric of
the universe at light speed the two
black holes eventually crashed into one
another and merged into one even bigger
black hole emitting a crescendo of waves
scientists have been searching for proof
of that collision and they just found it
now it's true LIGO a gravitational wave
observatory has had a few false alarms
but this time the astronomers are pretty
sure with a 99.9999 4 percent degree of
confidence so what does this mean first
it confirms Einstein's theory of general
relativity second now astrophysicists
can actually use the waves to do science
by recording the way gravitational waves
interact with a physical system
LIGO will let astronomers probe into the
details of the universe scientists can
learn what the universe was like in its
infancy what gravity is like at its most
extreme and how hyper dense matter
behaves the map of the universe just got
a bit more detailed you're welcome
Einstein